the dance of dragons a true telling by
grand maester monken
being a history of the war of targaryen
succession between the princess frienera
and aegon
second of his name that nearly destroyed
the realm
the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video
all right my friends in this video we
will be looking at the photos
hbo officially released yesterday as i'm
sure most of you know by now
hbo has been developing a new series
based in george rr martin's a song of
ice and fire universe
according to hbo's official website
house of the dragon will be set 300
years before the events of game of
thrones
it will show the downfall of house
targaryen during what is known as
the dance of dragons this was when house
targaryen
fought and killed their own blood over
the iron throne
now if you have seen some of my recent
videos you would know
hbo has been filming the first season of
this series for a little over a week
in the south of england actors have been
spotted filming scenes on one of the
sets they are using for house velaryon
another family of valyrian descent a lot
of photos have already been leaked onto
the internet
now that the cat is already out of the
bag it looks like hbo wanted to release
some high resolution photos
themselves these are the first official
images of house of the dragon
now if you have seen any of my recent
videos then you already know these
actors have been filming scenes
this isn't new information whatsoever
but what i do like about these photos is
we do get a good look at some of the
main characters from the show
in this first image released from hbo we
can see daemon and rhaenyra targaryen
now i have went into details about all
of these characters before but just in
case you're new here
i will briefly sum up who they are for
those of you that don't know
rhaenyra is the daughter of king viserys
targaryen
and daemon is the king's brother which
makes him rhaenyra's uncle
now although they are blood-related
daemon and rhaenyra eventually start a
romantic relationship
as you all know this is nothing new for
this family in fact we will see a lot of
this in house of the dragon
we will see dragon vs dragon in the
streets and we will see dragon vs dragon
in the sheets
it's what they do in this next photo we
have serato hightower
and his daughter allison hightower
serado hightower is the hand of the king
to viserys targaryen first of his name
serado hightower becomes bitter rivals
with king viserys's brother daemon
targaryen
sarado is basically worried that daemon
will become the new king after his
brother viserys dies
serato does just about everything he can
to make sure that doesn't happen
there was even a time when he wanted
viserys to name his daughter rhaenyra as
his heir
which king viserys eventually does once
again
daemon is cast to the side but since he
is in a relationship with rhaenyra
this isn't the worst thing that could
happen he would essentially be right at
her side while she ruled westeros
however before this happens king viserys
ends up getting married
to serato hightower's daughter alison
who you see in the photo next to him
not only is she young and gorgeous but
she is very fertile as well
this is basically the worst case
scenario for rhaenyra
now she will be cast aside also because
her father king viserys
and his new wife alicent end up having
several children together
the dance began as many dancers do with
an old man and a young girl
the queen had failed to produce a son
for her king so he anointed his daughter
the princess rhaenyra as his heir
but years later the king remarried and
his new wife
queen alicent of house hightower gave
him a son
feeble and foolish the old king refused
to change the succession he didn't even
see how his court had split into two
rival camps of blacks
and greens as soon as king viserys dies
allison ensures their son aegon gets the
iron throne instead of rhinera
and this is one of the many things that
leads to the dance of dragons
alicent and rhaenyra become bitter
rivals just like daemon in serato
hightower
now i'm obviously leaving out a lot of
other things but i have already made
other videos where i go into so much
more detail about the main events
surrounding the dance of dragons
in the last image hbo officially
released yesterday we have lord corliss
velaryon
who is a strong supporter of daemon and
rhaenyra
when ravens carried the news of aegon's
coronation to dragonstone princess
rhaenyra summoned her own black
council with her was her uncle and
husband damon targaryen
considered by many to be the most
dangerous man in westeros
few lords supported her but the greatest
of these was corliss valerian who
controlled the largest fleet in the
realm
and his targaryen wife rhaenys the old
king's sister
like so many of the other characters
during this time lord corliss velaryon
is an awesome character
like i said in my last video he's got
one hell of a fleet of ships
and he's also known as the wealthiest
man in westeros
not only that but his wife rhaenys
targaryen
is a dragon rider they can hit you from
the sea and they can hit you from the
air
lord corliss velaryon was also known as
the sea snake
the first lord commander of the
kingsguard but his fame did not come
from his skill of sword and lance and
shield
he got his fame from his voyages across
the seas where he was seeking new
horizons
he was a scion of house velaryon a
family of old and storied valyrian
heritage who came to westeros before the
targaryens as the histories would agree
now i really wish his wife was with him
in the photo i know a lot of fans have
issues with this casting choice but
i think he looks incredible i wasn't
really sure how he would look with the
white silvery hair
but i think it looks great i actually
like all of their outfits in these
photos and i'm looking forward to seeing
how all of the other characters look
hopefully hbo will release some more
images very soon
if not we will see the other actors
walking around on set
sooner or later anyways now like i said
since i have made a few videos about
these characters already
i will keep this short and sweet i just
wanted to give my thoughts on the
official photos
i think they look great and i am
confident hbo will do a great job at
finding other actors for all the other
characters
i barely knew who anyone was when i
first watched game of thrones but i
ended up loving almost every single
actor and actress they cast
in fact i think they did such a great
job the actors are now who i see in my
mind when i read the books
so if any of you are unsure about some
of these choices just wait until you see
some of the episodes
i think you will end up loving who they
went with either way
feel free to sound off with your own
thoughts down below as always i would
love to see what all of you have to say
now for those of you who like my version
of game of thrones season 9
i just want to let you know that i am
working on the next episode
i will have that out soon i had to
discuss all of this first because it is
major news right now but i will get back
to those videos so don't you worry
anyways i want to thank all of you for
watching this video i really appreciate
all of the support i have been getting
lately it really does mean a lot to me
i hope everyone has a great day i'll see
you soon bye
[Music]
you